bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live ce 16 avril
2021 nous allons vous faire vivre
l'hommage de la ville de conflans sainte
honorine à samuel pâtit un hommage qui
est en train de débuter nous allons
avoir dans quelques secondes les images
de ce qui se passe à conflans sainte
honorine en ce moment à 14h30 a eu lieu
l'hommage à samuel pâti dans
l'établissement scolaire dans le collège
dans lequel il enseignait et maintenant
a lieu une marche depuis ce collège du
bois d'aulne ou samuel bhatti a été
assassiné une marche avec les
enseignants les élèves une partie de
personnalités du monde politique on a pu
voir à l'instant valérie pécresse jean
michel blanquer le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine voilà on voit
ces images en direct en ce moment donc
c'est une marche qui se déroule entre
qui a pris des parts au collège du bois
donne et qui se dirige maintenant vers
la place de la liberté dans le centre
ville de conflans sainte honorine ou
devrait avoir lieu l'hommage organisé
par la mairie et la ville de conflans
sainte honorine il y a un an jour pour
jour ça mais elle pâtit été assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste près de son
collège des yvelines professeur
d'histoire géographie de 47 ans samuel
patty a été décapité pour avoir montré
des caricatures du prophète mahomet est
dans le cadre d'un cours sur la laïcité
est depuis hier les commémorations se
succèdent pour lui rendre hommage ils ce
matin la journée d'hommage à commencer
par une cérémonie organisée à 10 heures
par la ville d'eragny sur oise où
vivaient samuel pâti en présence de
proches d'amis de voisins et d'habitants
à cette occasion une fresque en
l'honneur de l'enseignant il a été
dévoilé à la même heure une autre
cérémonie se tenait cette fois ci au
ministère de l'éducation nationale dans
paris rue de grenelle en présence de
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et du premier
ministre jean castex ce dernier s'est
entretenu avec la famille de samuel
pâtit avant de dévoiler une plaque en sa
mémoire et de prononcer un discours une
troisième cérémonie a débuté tout à
l'heure je vous le dis à 14h30 au
collège du bois d'aulne de conflans
sainte honorine ou enseigner à ça mais
elle pâtit la famille du professeur
d'histoire-géographie était entouré de
jean michel blanquer de représentants du
ministère et de l'académie de versailles
d'organisations syndicales
d'associations de parents d'élèves et de
membres des équipes du collège des
prises de paroles des lectures de poèmes
et slam était prévu cet hommage n'était
pas accessible à la presse la presse
n'était pas conviée elle s'est déroulée
à huis clos et maintenant l'ensemble des
personnes présentes à cet hommage au
collège où enseigne et samuel pâtit se
dirige à pied vers le centre de conflans
sainte honorine pour donc participer aux
commémorations organisées cette fois-ci
par la ville de conflans et donc à
l'heure où on se parle vous le voyez sur
ces images un cortège s'est formé
et se dirige donc vers la place de la
liberté
les hommages continuent en cet après
midi le président de la république
emmanuel mâcon recevra les parents de
samuel pâti à l'elysée et en toute fin
de journée le maire de paris anne
hidalgo rebaptisera le square paul
painlevé qui se trouve face à la
sorbonne en square samuel pâtit bonjour
sophie de tarlé bonjour charlotte merci
d'être en direct avec nous pour
commenter cet hommage rendu par la ville
de conflans sainte honorine à samuel
pâtit vous êtes rédactrice en chef du
figaro étudiant on se souvient il y a un
an de la sidération de l'émotion
suscitée en france par le drame qu'a
représenté l'assassinât de sa mère
pattie on imagine également l'émotion
que représente en ce moment cet
anniversaire à ces commémorations pour
les habitants de conflans sainte
honorine et on voit elle est encore
palpable cette émotion suissa massa m'a
rappelé beaucoup de souvenirs des
commémorations qui avaient déjà lieu à
l'époque et des hommages qui avait eu
lieu au lendemain de l'assassinât
terrible en fait de samuel pâtit un an
un an déjà j'ai l'impression que c'était
il ya trois siècles
c'était
ça m'a remémoré cet épisode de tension
dans le pays aussi
ce n'était pas ce n'était pas simple
puisqu'il y avait il y avait des gens
qui disaient qu'ils avaient qu'il avait
eu tort de montrer ses caricatures
d'autres qu'il ne faisait que son métier
et que c'était un homme formidable bien
sûr et beaucoup il y avait beaucoup de
tension à l'époque autour du fait
d'avoir montré ses caricatures et c'est
vrai que ça mais ça m'est revenu en
mémoire mais aujourd'hui c'est le moment
de c'est le moment pour toute la société
de finalement de rappeler dans notre
soutien notre soutien à ce qu'il a fait
notre soutien à
son travail et il ya plusieurs phrases
de jean michel blanquer qui m'ont qui
m'ont frappé que j'aimerais vous vous
lire
jean michel blanquer qui est intervenu
est intervenue ce matin au ministère de
l'éducation nationale ou été dévoilée
donc une plaque en hommage à ces mêmes
petits d'abord il a d une phrase très
forte qui m'a qui m'a marqué c'est
samuel pâtit avait raison et comme je le
disais à l'époque et encore aujourd'hui
et encore lors des reportages qui ont
été faits dans certains collèges où on
voit les collégiens 10 mais est-ce que
c'est autorisé de montrer les
caricatures qu'on a le droit à ce qu'il
avait le droit de le faire et là de dire
cette phrase samuel pâtit avait raison
c'est vraiment fort c'est pour dire pour
clore le débat oui il faisait son métier
il le faisait dans le cadre dans le
cadre dacourt de mc donc d'éducation
morale et civique sur la liberté
d'expression
c'était pour appeler aussi sans doute un
événement tragique puisque l'attentât
l'attentât de et la mort des
dessinateurs de charlie hebdo un
événement qui a frappé la france donc
c'est aussi un événement historique et
pour parler de cet événement historique
pour parler de la liberté d'expression
et et du concept même de la laïcité en
france il a montré ses caricatures
sachant qu'il le faisait chaque année
sans qu on ait
à redire en fait moi quand j'avais
interrogé des professeurs ils m'avaient
certains m'avaient dit oui c'est quelque
chose que nous faisons aussi donc ce
n'était pas quelque chose de scandaleux
en fait est là en disant cela ce matin
lors de la pose de la plaque en
l'honneur de samuel petit dans le dans
le l'entrée du du ministère de
l'éducation nationale rue de grenelle à
paris et bien samuel pâtit avez raison
ça ça doit résonner fortement pour tous
les enseignants pour toute la société
pour tous les élèves aussi qu'ils se
posaient encore la question lors d'un
reportage
de publier par figaro où il y avait des
collégiens qui disent aimer il a le
droit il avait le droit de le faire et
sinon oui il avait le droit oui c'était
son métier oui c'était un excellent
professeur et c'est de le rappeler c'est
important après une autre phrase de jean
michel blanquer rc les professeurs ne
doivent pas se sentir seul
ça c'est aussi important on se souvient
à quel point il ya une forme de solitude
chez lui dans cette caverne de l'épisode
2 pas de vagues ou en 2018 avec suite au
hashtag balancement port et bien il y
avait eu un hashtag pas de vague où les
professeurs se plaignait de la solitude
de face aux problèmes liés à la violence
scolaire
et aussi au problème de la laïcité donc
les professeurs ne peuvent pas se sentir
seul et puis une autre phrase que jean
michel blanquer a prononcé aussi ce
matin c'est une insulte à la démocratie
donc c'était une insulte à la démocratie
et ça aussi ce sont des paroles paroles
fortes qui doivent résonner pour toute
la société et pas uniquement pour les
pour les enseignants mais c'est une
façon de de guerre aux enseignants vous
n'êtes pas seuls nous sommes là
l'institution est là et aussi de voilà
deux coups et beck finalement à tous
ceux qui ont pu dire même encore
récemment qu'il avait eu tort de faire
son métier si vous venez de nous
rejoindre en direct sur figaro l'arrivée
sur notre chaîne figaro live sur youtube
nous sommes en train de vous faire vivre
les l'hommage organisé par la ville de
conflans sainte honorine à samuel
pâtissent ce professeur assassiné il y a
un an jour pour jour un cortège est
parti du collège où enseigne et samuel
parti et samuel pâtit pour se diriger
vers cette place de la libération que se
trouve maintenant les individus qui fait
qu'ils font partie du cortège les
personnes présentes dans ce cortège
était présente au collège pour les
commémorations tout à l'heure on y
reconnaît évidemment jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale à ses côtés le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros on
a pu entrapercevoir et voir une rose
blanche à la main valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
des élèves sont présents également des
professeurs font partie de ce cortège
qui s'est rassemblée sur sur cette place
où va se dérouler un hommage donc comme
je vous le disais organisé voilà valérie
pécresse qui dépose la rose blanche qui
l'accompagnait avec ainsi que que les
membres de ce cortège jusqu'à une photo
de samuel pâtit présente à côté d'une
estrade
et d'une une image qui a été
affichée en hommage à samuel pâtit donc
des élus sont présents des membres de la
famille de samuel pâtit également on
peut entendre de la musique si la régie
iad bekir en régie pub peut monter un
peu le le retour pour la fois qu'on est
le son de l'atmosphère présents sur
place beaucoup de monde 1 sophie de
tarlé 1 aujourd'hui oui
beaucoup de monde certainement déjà aux
eaux autour du collège tout à l'heure à
14h30 quand toutes les commémorations et
beaucoup de monde également au coeur de
cette ville de conflans sainte honorine
oui beaucoup d élèves aussi c'est
important qu'ils sont tout proches de
jean michel bancaire et valérie pécresse
c'est important de les associer
ceux qui ont eu comme professeur samuel
pâti l'an dernier parce qu'il faut vous
rappeler que c'est évidemment un
traumatisme pour pour les élèves
présents pour les enseignants pour cette
ville assez tranquille c'est pas une
ville chaude de banlieue parisienne pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas confiance en
europe solidaire fait un quartier très
tranquille enfin va regarder ça faisait
mal lionel tarlet on va regarder les
visages fermés ému peut-être aussi 2d
jean michel blanquer et valérie pécresse
qui sont en train de se recueillir
devant la photo de de sa mère pattie
[Musique]
non
pour
le cortège vient d'arriver je vous le
disais sur cette place de la liberté à
conflans sainte honorine un cortège
rassemblé pour participer à l'hommage
rendu par la ville de conflans sainte
honorine à samuel pâtit
voilà les cameramans se mettent en place
pour pour assister à cet hommage donc
voilà vous la voyez cette foule réunie
des étudiants des jeunes des adultes
bien sûr parmi lesquels on imagine il ya
des professeurs des enseignants
des amis de samuel pâti des habitants de
conflans sainte honorine également et
puis on a vu les officiels il ya un
orchestre également qui joue de la
musique depuis que le cortège s'est
rassemblé on a pu voir jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale valérie pécresse présidente de
la région ile de france le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros
voilà des prises de parole devrait avoir
lieu
je suis en direct avec à mes côtés
sophie de tarlé qui est rédactrice en
chef au figaro étudiant qui est là pour
répondre à vos questions et a réagi et
qui est là pour répondre aussi à vous à
vos commentaires sur les tchats du
figaro vous n'hésitez pas à nous en
faire part
oui c'est
beaucoup de les collègues bien sûr de
confiance ou léman de du collège parce
que si certains après après le drame
sont ont quitté ce collège en fait on
demandait une affectation dans un autre
établissement
la plupart sont restés dans dans l'est
dans la même école et bien sûr les
élèves on était allé les interrogés sont
la plupart sont restés toujours dans le
même établissement en fait c'est pas les
talibans qui avaient fui après le après
le drame donc pour la plupart beaucoup
connaissaient le samuel pas tiqué je
rappelle est mort à l'âge de 47 ans qui
est le papa d'un enfant qu'il y avait
cinq ans à l'époque donc on toutes nos
pensées vont vont
- sa famille évidemment ce qu'on peut
dire sophie tard les quelques mots sur
sur sa mythique et est il qu'en disaient
ses collègues et ses élèves oui c'est
important de rappeler que lorsqu'on a
interrogé ses collègues et et bien sûr
les élèves qu'il avait eu comme
professeur ce qui ressort c'est un homme
très drôle qui avaient de l'autorité sur
ses élèves ce n'est pas un professeur
débordés non pas du tout c'est un
professeur qui était alors je relis mes
mots c'est un homme de dialogue qui ne
voulait pas choquer c'est ce qui ressort
il donnait envie d'apprendre toujours
habillé avec une chemise
en jean il jouait pas le prof copains
pas du tout c'était c'est un prof un
professeur qui n'était pas
jaune dans le métier en fait il avait
suivi des études en classe préparatoire
à lyon puis obtenu le cap face à lyon et
il avait ensuite été nommé
en région parisienne
on écoute la minute de silence
merci
viens d'assister à la minute de silence
en hommage à sa mère pattie les visages
étaient graves beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion
pour cet hommage à sa mère pattie
organisée par la mairie de conflans
sainte honorine la réglisse on les a vus
ces visages graves beaucoup d'émotion
les collégiens soient présents devant
les officiels et qu'ils soient associés
à cette cérémonie
on va écouter le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros
qui intervient maintenant revenus non
bois aujourd'hui
ici place de la liberté au rendre
hommage à sim elle pâtit
je vous remercie d'autant plus qu'il ya
près d'un an dans les jours
et les semaines qui ont suivi l'attentât
nos rassemblements
nos échanges
vos mots de réconfort aux messages de
soutien
m'ont permis à titre personnel un sans
doute permis à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous de surmonter cette épreuve
l'attentât qui aurait pu nous diviser
nous a encore plus
soudés
nous cache pas une certaine émotion
j'appréhendais depuis plusieurs jours ce
moment précis vous serez amené à revenir
devant vous sur cette soirée douloureuse
du 16 octobre 2011
le 16 octobre 2020 restera un jour à
jamais marquée d'une pierre blanche dans
l'histoire de conflans sainte honorine
c'était un jour comme un autre dans
notre commune c'était un jour comme un
autre sur la place cuillère et les quais
de seine
les promeneurs profitaient des derniers
rayons du soleil d'automne sous le
regard millénaire de la tour bons
joueurs
c'était un jour comme un autre dans le
parc du prieuré
c'était un jour comme un autre plateau
du moulin à carnot aux roches à
chaudière et afin d'oise
c'est un jour comme un autre au collège
de bois d'olives et de la console
scolaire
c'était un jour comme un autre pour
samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie
un jour qui s'est amené dans l'europe
nous avons probablement toutes et tous
un souvenir est fier de ce que nous
étions en train de faire lorsque nous
avons appris que cet acte inqualifiable
venait de se produire
ce jour là j'étais dans mon bureau à
l'hôtel de ville
à mes collaborateurs avenue de
l'informer que deux agents la police
municipale avaient été projetés à nam
armés aux abords du collège de boston
j'ai immédiatement appelé ces deux
agents qui m'ont expliqué en détail la
situation
sous le choc j'ai mis quelques instants
à lisez ce qui venait de se passer
ce jour là
conflans sainte honorine
la commune de naissance
cette commune dans laquelle j'ai grandi
dans laquelle je suis allé à l'école
cette commune d'ordinaire si calme et si
agréable
venez d'être le théâtre d'un monstrueux
assassinat elle allait bien malgré elle
être au centre des préoccupations
et des attentes
je me suis immédiatement du pur du
surplace alors que mon téléphone
portable et ses sept sonné
la nouvelle commencé à se répandre et
tout le monde voulait en savoir plus
c'était le début d'une très longue et
éprouvante soirée au terme de laquelle
je savais qu'il y aurait un avant et un
après 16 octobre 2020 quand
on dit que derrière chaque grand homme
il ya une femme
il ya chaque grand homme il y réussit
probablement un professeur
l'avons tous le souvenir d'un professeur
passionnant qu'est ce vous éveillez nous
faire grandir
changer notre regard sur le monde
pour des générations de collégiens du
bol donne c'est myopathies était ce
professeur
pour ses confrères du collège était un
collègue apprécié de tous mais il était
aussi un fils d'un compagnon
à peine
aujourd'hui nous avons une pensée émue
pour sa famille pour ses collègues pour
ces élèves et pour tous ceux qui ont
croisé sa route et qu'ils apprécient
ce qu'ils gardent le souvenir d'un
professeur impliqués animé par une
indéfectible ambitions de transmettre
son savoir à ses élèves et de les
accompagner vers la réussite
j'ai aussi une pensée pour nos policiers
municipaux et nationaux qui ont été les
premiers sur les lieux il pointe est
directement confronté aux terroristes
leur courage et leurs interventions
décisives ont permis de neutraliser
rapidement le terroriste est sans doute
d'éviter d'autrement il reste marqué
durablement par cette expérience
comme nous l'avons fait l'année dernière
après l'attentât qui a coûté la vie nous
sommes réunis pour rendre hommage à
semer le pâtis sur la place de la
liberté
avec nous
c'est toute la france qui lui rend
hommage
ce midi la famille de samuel patty a été
reçu à l'elysée par rame les présidents
des républiques et son épouse
en début d'après midi le ministre de
l'éducation nationale accompagnés de
professeurs de collégiens et de leurs
parents s'est rendu au collège de
bologne ils ont été rejoints par des
élus du conseil municipal de conflans
sainte honorine pour déposer
symboliquement une rose blanche en
mémoire du professeur pâti
en fin d'après-midi le square samuel
bâti sera inaugurée face à université de
la sorbonne haut lieu de la culture et
de l'enseignement où le président de la
république lui a revendu l'hommage
national l'année dernière
à la suite de l'attentât du 16 octobre
2020 la france entière et est en deuil
pendant des mois des courriers de
soutien et de reconnaissance à
destination de la famille de samuel pas
tillon a fait par dizaines à la mairie
de conflans sainte honorine nous avons
aussi reçu des demandes de nombreuses
communes qui souhaitait donner le nom de
cellules hépatiques un établissement
scolaire à une rue une place publique
les centaines d'anonymes ont également
témoigné de leur attachement à samuel
petit
collectivités territoriales le citoyen
chacun à notre façon nous avons voulu
les rendre hommage
rendre hommage à l'homme
mais aussi à ceux qui le représentait
aux valeurs qu'ils défendent elles
pour avoir voulu
éveillé ses élèves et les sensibiliser à
la liberté d'expression
samuel patil a déclenché l'ire des
extrémistes religieux pour qui la
liberté est une aberration
rendre hommage à saluer le bâti c'est
aussi rendre hommage à la liberté
d'expression qui lui était si cher c'est
pour avoir montré un dessin de presse à
ses élèves qu'il a été assassiné
de l'arrêt firmes ont ensemble
aujourd'hui
non
un dessin de presse ne doit pas tuer
un dessin de presse de nous faire
réfléchir
susciter la discussion le débat
il peut bien sûr des clercs
nous avons le droit de ne pas être
d'accord ce sont ces désaccords et ses
débats permanents qui font en france
notre identité
notre adn
notre force
est donc légitime que nous rendions
hommage à ses mails pâtit parent un
livre représentant les dessins de presse
ce livre auquel ont contribué des
dessinateurs français et étrangers
le témoignage de notre attachement à
cette liberté d'expression je tiens à
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont contribué à la création et à la
réalisation de ce livre en particulier
dessinateurs qui ont bien voulu se
prêter à cet exercice est on certain
sont présents cet après midi
plus qu'un hommage
ce livre traduit notre volonté d'ancrer
et la mémoire de samuel pâti dans
l'histoire de notre ville tout en
rappelant les valeurs qu'il avait fait
sienne
dans les jours qui ont suivi l'attentât
max evans usa
nous sommes demandés comment nous
pouvions en tant que commune
contribuer à la promotion de ces valeurs
pour que plus jamais une telle tragédie
ne puisse se reproduire à conflans
sainte honorine ou ailleurs
nous avons initié l'élaboration d'un
ambitieux plan d'action pour la jeunesse
et la citoyenneté
nous n'avons rapidement fixer les
orientations et aux concours d'acteurs
locaux à l'accompagnement des jeunes
associations sportives communauté
éducative bailleurs sociaux et
représentants des cultes
un projet porté collectivement pour que
notre ville puisse se relever
l'objectif de ce plan est de promouvoir
le vivre ensemble dans le respect
de chacun et de chacune dans le respect
de nos valeurs communes
nous devons plus que jamais donner à nos
enfants l'envi de s'impliquer la sorte d
exprimer de partage et de découvrir
l'autre
un certain nombre de projets ont déjà
été mis dans ce cadre je pense à la
remise aux enfants d'un passeport du
civisme qui valorise et récompense
l'engagement citoyen
notre action verront le jour prochaine
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous avons
besoin d'unité
c'est pourquoi il nous faut nous
mobiliser pour défendre les valeurs
républicaines et sensibiliser le plus
jeune ce sont ces valeurs qui permettent
de favoriser le vivre ensemble la
solidarité
l'entr'aide et l'écoutent
au premier rang de ses valeurs la
liberté d'expression que samuel pâte y
avait à coeur d'enchaîner à ses élèves
cet hommage nous rappelle aussi à quel
point il nous faut faire preuve de
vigilance et des poutres
nous devons rappeler le rôle primordial
que jouent les enseignants dans la
promotion ses valeurs auprès de la
jeunesse les parents partagent également
cette responsabilité
je veux dire à nouveau aux familles
conflanais zh à quel point il est
essentiel que nous travaillons tous
ensemble pour enrayer les phénomènes de
violence tels que le harcèlement
notamment sur réseaux sociaux et déceler
d'éventuels signes de radicalisation
un an après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit
la vie a repris son cours
mais c'était vraiment arrêter
la vie a suivi son cours à conflans
sainte honorine ponctuée par am les
différents événements qui rythment la
vie de notre commune nos enfants ont
continué à l'école les bateaux entiers
de naviguer sur la seine nous avons
continué mes chers conflanais à nous
promener sur les quais de seine à pied
ou à vélo
à fréquenter les terrasses des
restaurants à nous engager dans la vie
de notre commune et dans les
associations
nous avons continué à être solidaires
comme nous l'avons toujours été
un an après nous avons un sécher nos
larmes nous avons pensé nos blessures
nous avons repris le cours de nos vies
sans pour autant oublier
ni pardonner
ensemble nous sommes relevés
ensemble nous poursuivrons notre lutte
acharnée pour la défense de notre
liberté de notre mode de vie et des
valeurs qu'incarne la devise gravé au
fronton de nos écoles cette devise est
celle de notre république et qui fait
notre fierté
liberté égalité fraternité
vive qu'on pense à nos narines il à
public vive la france
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
oui
e
alors combien
entendre la marseillaise jouée après
l'intervention du maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent brosse
une intervention brièvement interrompu
par l'évanouissement d'une personne
présente dans le public qui est un peu
perturbé donc le discours du maire le
maire qui a rendu hommage donc à samuel
pâtit un hommage auquel vous assistez
qui est organisé par la ville de
conflans sainte honorine
dont on pourra retenir un parmi
l'intervention de laurent bros ces mots
d'abord le fait qu'il a grandi lui même
au sein de cette commune angan
endeuillées et que le jour où samuel
partie et est décédé aurait dû être un
jour effectivement comme les autres
qu'il ya eu effectivement un avant et
après il ya un avant et après le drame
qui a impacté cette commune de conflans
sainte honorine et l'horreur qui s'est
immiscé dans un quotidien auquel tout le
monde pouvait s'identifier
il est revenu également laurent bros sur
le symbole que représente la sorbonne
dans le fait que un square va porter
désormais son nom un square qui va être
inaugurée ce soir en tout cas en fin de
journée aujourd'hui en honneur de samuel
pâtit oui et puis surtout il a parlé
aussi de il a rappelé et finalement
comment c'était le déroulement de cette
journée pour lui et ça j'ai trouvé ça
très très fort
il a rappelé le rôle des policiers qui
ont comme
neutraliser en fait le terroriste en
fait ils l'ont tué
quelques minutes après après
l'assassinât de ces mêmes ne pâtit il a
rappelé cette journée où il a reçu les
pleins de messages plein de textos sur
tours de téléphone et lui s'est rendu
directement sur place et
le finalement le choc pour lui pour la
commune et le choc évidemment pour les
policiers qui ont qui ont vu la scène
qui ont qui ont tué le terrorisme un
terroriste qui n'avait que je rappelle
que 18 ans donc il y avait deux choses
aussi qui m'ont frappé s'il a rappelé le
rôle de la mission de sensibiliser les
jeunes aux valeurs républicaines et puis
aussi
d'être beaucoup plus sensible au
phénomène des réseaux sociaux et du
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux et
je vous interromps juillet parce que je
crois qu'ils vont dévoiler quelque chose
je vous laisserai continuer juste après
voilà
c'est un grand livre effectivement un
grand livre ouvert
pour nous dévoile que le maire laurent
bros des boilles aux côtés de jean
michel jeanpierre ministre l'éducation
nationale grand livre ouvert avec des
dessins
donc j'imagine la pluralité des auteurs
de ces dessins
qui sont donc représentées à l'intérieur
de la liberté de la presse sur la
liberté d'expression pardon voilà on
distingue à gauche de l'image 1 valérie
pécresse donc présidente de la région
ile de france qui a assisté aujourd'hui
à cet hommage à samuel pâtit rendu par
la ville de conflans sainte honorine
et je vous cite vous êtes quelques uns
sur les réseaux sociaux du figaro à
faire part de baume dans mon commentaire
et de votre émotion que je citerai
taille-là cohen bacrie qui nous dit un
beau discours pensée pour la famille de
monsieur pâtit paix à son âme dit un
autre mais il faut être tolérant envers
plusieurs religions il s'agit
effectivement d'être d'être tolérant
alors qu'on voit à l'image
cette
représentation sa belle pâtit ce dessin
de ça mais elle pâtit son visage qui
nous est devenu très familier depuis un
an et donc ce grand livre ouvert
avec ses dessins représentaient à
l'intérieur par différents auteurs et
qui met en avant la liberté d'expression
jean michel blanquer air qui s'adresse à
quelques enfants
avec à ses côtés laurent bros je vous ai
interrompu sophie de tarlé vous disiez
oui on en parlera dation ensuite des
dessins offert par par ces grands
dessinateurs de presse qui rappelle
l'importance a fait écho bien sûr avec
avec l'épisode
épouvantable de charlie de charlie hebdo
le maire a rappelé oui je dis c'est le
rôle des réseaux sociaux parce qu'en
fait on se souvient que avant
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie il y
avait une
aar seulement deux dindes et par un
parent d'élève
et d'autres qui ont mis finalement le
nom de sa mère pattie sur sur la place
publique et
donc le rôle des réseaux sociaux
évidemment dans dans le meurtre du
professeur et puis et puis l'importance
de leur rôle des familles pour déceler
les signes de radicalisation chez les
jeunes ça fait écho bien sûr au fait que
le
terroriste était très jeune puisque
c'était on le rappelle un russe
d'origine tchétchène de 18 ans seulement
donc et donc on
a berné ils le discours commence et ça
ce drame aurait pu être divisé et puis
finalement il nous a unis alors c'est
peut-être un peu fort mais quand même
c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui on est
tous unis au delà de ceux qui pensent
que il aurait pas dû etc on est tous
unis on est tous derrière samuel petit
camp là on l'a entendu laurent laurent
brosse le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine il a dit aussi
que rendre hommage à l'homme s'était
aussi rendre hommage à ce qu'il
représentait et il représentait la
liberté d'expression oui tout à fait ce
n'est pas ce n était pas un laïcards
agressif prête à tout pour fauqué les
élèves etc enfin tous les témoignages
montrent que c'était un professeur
expérimenté
qui faisait secours dans le cadre très
finalement
normes et de l'éducation morale et
civique sur la liberté d'expression et
pour montrer la liberté d'expression
pour étayer son cours finalement mais
comme beaucoup de professeurs en france
en fait il n'est pas du tout le seul
à faire ça en voyage aux pins et
jacquelin alors oui ça ce sont des
images capturées ce matin diffusé ce
matin c'est dans l'enceinte du ministère
de l'éducation nationale au moment où on
dévoilait cette plaque en hommage à sa
mère pattie on va revoir ces images un
an michel blanquer remise l'éducation
nationale en présence de jean castex le
premier ministre voilà cette plaque qui
va être professeur d'histoire géographie
et d'enseignement moral et civique très
importante parce que c'est dans le cas
de secours
assassinés alors j'avais
noté mais voilà voilà pour la hutte donc
lionel jospin voilà on devra assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste pour avoir
enseigné les valeurs de la république
dont la liberté d'expression cette
plaque va être accrochés dans
dans le hall d'accueil du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et le maire a
rappelé que même si on n'est pas
toujours d'accord entre nous on est en
france on aime batailler à on aime on
n'aime voilà on est pas on n'est pas
forcément d'accord mais c'est ce qui
fait l'adn notre voilà de nos pays le
fait de pouvoir justement discuté
cela batailler et c'est ça que a voulu
détruire finalement le terroriste en
turquie sa mère pattie laurent brossard
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine qui
s'exprimait il ya encore quelques
minutes a également précisé qu'un dessin
de presse ne doit pas tuer ouais tout à
fait un
dessin de presse et bien ce n'est pas la
première fois que qu'il tue puisque
charlie hebdo
finalement c'était aussi un dessin de
presse donc ça rappelle beaucoup de
souvenirs terribles pour nous
mais on a vu que les terroristes
finalement
tuer
tuer tout le monde en fait un prêtre âgé
à on l'a vu un policier à toulouse
des écoliers juifs
savent un professeur aujourd'hui enfin
il ya un an
finalement des passants des déjà des
gens qui vont qui vont juste regarder le
14 juillet comme comme à nice tout le
monde tout le monde finalement est
concerné c'est toute la société
française
j'avais vu parfois que lorsqu'il ya un
attentat c'est oui mais c'est parce
qu'il l'a bien cherché oui il l'a fait
ça etc non ça peut tuer tout le monde
tout le monde peut être concerné une
infirmière un journaliste un dessinateur
de presse un magistrat un militaire
qu'ils soient juifs catholiques
musulmans watts et tout le monde a été
touchée par les attentats
c'est ça qui est important de le
rappeler
si vous nous rejoignez maintenant en
direct sur figaro live nous avons
assister nous avons fait vivre l'hommage
rendu par la ville de conflans sainte
honorine à ça mais elle pâtit ce
professeur assassiné décapité il ya un
an jour pour jour
devant son le collège dans lequel il
enseignait le collège du bois d'aulne à
conflans sainte honorine un hommage lui
a été rendu donc ce matin à
au ministère de l'éducation nationale où
une plaque a été dévoilée un autre
hommage lui a été rendu dans
l'établissement dans lequel il
enseignait et puis les vendredi à un
hommage qui a été rendu dans les écoles
de fraps arrivant alors il ya eu
quelques petits incidents bien sûr comme
souvent dans ces moments là oui je le 98
20 18 ans 1,7 et donc voilà ont été
relevés hier suite à ces hommages qui
ont été demandés on va dire par jean
michel blanquer air qui a demandé
effectivement que les enseignants
consacrent une heure de leur cours oui
donc ils ont pu écouter par exemple
enfin lire la lettre de jean jaurès aux
instituteurs et aux institutrices une
lettre qui avait déjà été lu lors de au
lendemain de la mort de samuel pattes il
ya un an ils ont pu aussi regarder une
vidéo de robert badinter sur la laïcité
il y avait certains éléments qui étaient
sur le site eduscol qui permettait aux
professeurs de d'avoir une heure de
discussion avec leurs élèves
donc alors tous n'ont pas eu lieu mais
globalement ce qui avait été demandé
vendredi avec bien sûr
des incidents qui ont été enlevés les
insultes des menaces
alors je sais pas si ce chiffre de 98
qui me semble assez faible quand même
est sous-évalué ou pas mais en tout cas
le ministre avait rappelé que les
incidents qui les plus les plus les plus
inquiétants seront suivis de suite bien
sûr on va dire écoutez si la régie ne
nous le permet l'intervention une partie
de l'intervention de jean castex ce
matin un premier ministre s'est exprimé
en direct depuis le ministère de
l'éducation nationale au moment où on
allait dévoiler une plaque en hommage à
sa mère pattie c'est quand vous voulez à
la régie pour voilà que nos hommes
qui voulaient faire son métier un métier
noble exigeants
et parfois ingrat
un homme qui n'aspirait qu'à transmettre
les valeurs de liberté de laïcité de
tolérance
de libre arbitre que nous ont légué les
lumières et qui ont été conquises par
tout un peuple au prix de combats si
souvent ardent voilà que pour ces motifs
un serviteur de la république a été
assassiné
c'est pourquoi mesdames et messieurs
rendre hommage samuel bâti c'est rendre
hommage à la république
voilà c'était les mots du premier
ministre jean castex ce matin depuis le
ministère de l'éducation nationale où
une plaque a été dévoilée en hommage à
assam ltée pâti en en présence de jean
michel blanquer herminis de l'éducation
nationale et des membres de la famille
de samuel pâtit
nous avons assisté tout à l'heure à
l'hommage de la ville de conflans sainte
honorine où se sont réunis les officiels
quelques officiels jean michel blanquer
valérie pécresse on a pu voir yves jadot
yves jégo yves jégo pardon et puis
delphine batho également le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine s'est également
exprimée dans un long discours laurent
bros où il a rappelé les valeurs
essentielles transmises par par les
enseignants le fait qu'il faille les
respecte et qu'un dessin de ne doit ne
doit pas tuer un dessin de presse ne
doit pas tuer et c'était l'occasion
aussi pour la ville de conflans sainte
honorine de dévoiler un livre monumental
un livre ouvert avec des dessins de
presse en hommage à la liberté
d'expression et à samuel pâtit
sophie de tarlé
rédactrice en chef du figaro étudiant
est avec nous encore quelques minutes
pour revenir sur ces hommages nombreux
et qui se déroule depuis hier vendredi
15 octobre et qui finiront aujourd'hui
par l'inauguration d'un square devant la
sorbonne l'université de la sorbonne
c'est un symbole très fort cette
université et devant laquelle un square
va être inaugurée donc c'était
le square qui s'appelait jusqu'à présent
alors le nom ne va pas être beau mais
bien sûr
je vais pas levée donc le nom d'un
manille peine à manier pas être
mathématicien pardon et hommes
politiques
du début du xxème siècle je crois bien
donc il le nom de scène elle pâtit va
être donnée à ce soir
enfin on va lancer l'intervention de
jean-michel blanquer ce matin non ce
matin au ministère de l'éducation
nationale on va entendre ces mots à jean
michel blanquer
c'était hier par dont il transmettait
aussi les valeurs samuel pâtit
à commencer par la liberté d'expression
bien sûr celle qui offre à chacun la
possibilité d'émettre un avis et cette
liberté passe par le respect de la
liberté des femmes toutes les libertés
c'est une liberté qui s'exerce en
respectant de la même façon celle
d'autrui samuel pâtit former ainsi de
futurs citoyens
les élèves comme vous
tu es donc l'intervention de hier de
jean michel blanquer vendredi 15 octobre
c'était donc ayez qui mettait en avant
de nouveaux là l'importance de la
liberté d'expression
sophie de tarlé je vous est interrompue
juste avant l'intervention de
jean-michel oui là pour rediffuser oui
y'a gouard qui va être inauguré la
sorbonne exactement donc devant l'hôtel
de cluny donc c'est important
c'est un endroit emblématique
dans présence ce sera en présence du
maire de bien sûr du maire de paris anne
hidalgo
c'est important je sais qu'il ya aussi
des écoles qui ont demandé alors pour
l'instant je crois qu'il ya une école
maternelle qui a nommé aujourd'hui dans
sur la côte d'azur samuel pâtit
alors évidemment il ya toujours des
dissensions au niveau du est faut-il
appeler un y avait des gens qui
demandaient il faudrait que dans chaque
département il ya une école samuel pâtit
donc ce n'est pas encore tranché mais il
y a eu des demandes en effet pour des
rudes et
des squares della sera un square en
plein paris devant la sorbonne donc
c'est un endroit très emblématique
le premier ministre a aussi rappelé
quelque chose très important c'est le
fait que c'est un métier difficile
professeurs c'est un métier parfois
souvent ingrat
ce n'était pas la première fois qu'il y
avait eu enfin qu'on a mis sur la table
fait que les professeurs étaient
confrontés à des problèmes face à la
liberté d'expression à le fait de parler
religion à l'école déjà en 2018 il y
avait eu un livre qui était paru sur une
prière pour l'école qui de frédéric
béguin qui parlait de ça où il avait
interrogé des professeurs au sujet de la
difficulté ils avaient de parler de
parler de la laïcité la liberté
d'expression on se souvient du mouvement
pas de vague où les professeurs se
sentait vraiment démunis face à cela
donc là aujourd'hui
alors aussi où on a parfois on peut
parler de crise des vocations pour le
métier de professeur bien sûr je pense
aussi aux étudiants qui nous écoutent
peut-être et en voyant cette
commémoration certains pourraient se
dire et bien est ce que ça vaut le coup
finalement d'être professeur
donc il faut aussi leur dire que la
france le gouvernement et toute la
société française
reste derrière le derrière les
enseignants parce que il faut aussi
donner envie aux enfants et aux lycéens
qui nous écoutent et qui qui vend à
l'école aujourd'hui et qui ont envie
d'être enseignant qui a envie de devenir
professeur d'histoire-géo leur dire
écoutez on est avec vous vous ne serez
jamais seuls et ça c'est très très très
important parce que là c'est l'avenir
aussi de la profession qui se joue enfin
je veux dire par là que va penser à un
enfant qui va regarder cette cérémonie à
la télévision cette équipe maman c'est
un professeur il y a été assassiné c'est
pas facile après de dire je veux être
professeur d'histoire géo c'est pas
facile de d'entendre des ses parents
dire t'es sûr que c'est un métier pour
toi c'est pas un peu dangereux enfin
avant dangereux ça voulait c'était
militaires éventuellement policiers
c'était un métier dangereux mais je sais
pas moi quand j'étais au lycée je ne
pensais pas qu'elle professeurs
pouvaient être métier un métier
dangereux donc c'est important aussi de
dire les jeunes qui nous écoutent et qui
est au lycée ou à l'université qui
préparaient des concours pour devenir
professeur eh bien il faut leur donner
envie aussi leur dire qu'il ya une unité
au sein de la société et qu'on va les
aider et ça c'est très important de les
aider à faire leur métier parce que
quand même c'est quand même assez
ça peut être aussi assez angoissant donc
maintenant de se dire que finalement
professeur oui c'est comme militaire
c'est partir à la guerre et on n'a pas
envie de ça parce que le lycée c'est pas
c'est pas une zone de guerre quoi c'est
une zone où on apprend où on s'épanouit
on est heureux on rit ça mais elle pâtit
avait la réputation d'être quelqu'un de
très drôle car beaucoup de moi avec ses
élèves donc c'est un endroit où on est
on peut être heureux
on se fait des amis parfois en rampant
son conjoint donc tout ça on a envie de
le dire et le voilà le lycée et les
c'est pas une zone de guerre donc c'est
un endroit qui peut être saisie où on
fabrique finalement le français de
demain donc c'est important de de donner
envie aux jeunes d'aujourd'hui de
devenir enseignant eh bien on va se
quitter sur sur les images de cette
petite fille cette petite élève ce sont
des images d'archivés tournées l'an
dernier lors d'une minute de silence en
hommage à samuel pâtit qui avaient été
assassinés donc le 16 octobre 2020
samuel pâtit ce professeur dont on
rendait à qui on rend des hommages
aujourd'hui et hier déjà aujourd'hui on
vous a permis de suivre en direct
l'hommage rendu par la ville de conflans
sainte honorine à ce professeur samuel
parties en présence d'officiels en
présence de jean michel blanquer remise
l'éducation nationale mais de valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france entre autres un cortège et des
enfants des enseignants des proches de
samuel pâtit qui avaient tous
quitté le collège du bois d'auch où
enseignait samuel paty et qui a rendu
également hommage en amont de l'hommage
de la ville de conflans sainte honorine
et un cortège s'est déplacé depuis ce
collège à pied à travers les rues de
conflans sainte honorine et en tête de
cortège les personnalités politiques qui
l'écharpé tricolore
sur le corps on va dire et une rose
blanche à la main ont
déposer cette rose sur l'image de samuel
pâtit à l'arrivée sur la place de la
liberté également à noter donc une
intervention du maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine
et puis le fait d'avoir dévoré le livre
ouvert qui était dévoilée sur cette
place des
sénateurs et des dessins des
dessinateurs un grand livre et vert
magnifique livre en hommage donc à ça
mais elle pâtit dont on voit encore une
fois le visage derrière moi et sophie de
tarlé merci beaucoup sophie mais la
taille rédactrice en chef au figaro
étudiant d'avoir apporté à ce direct
toute l'humanité et toute l'expertisé
nécessaire en ce jour merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis en direct sur figaro
live et sur notre chaîne youtube a très
vite pour un autre direct et un autre
événement